[Applause]
[Music]
hello and thank
you and welcome Anne
Carson to the
stage I had a heavy bag with me I
carried all your books with me so
they're here we're going to talk about
them okay
how are you fine thanks
good how are you
[Applause]
all there's
water yeah I'm a little
nervous an Carson is the writer I love
the most
and we have spoken on stage many times
and I'm always a little nervous but I'm
very happy and honored that we are
speaking again
today I want to
start by talking about yesterday's
performance that I think a lot of people
saw it Stacks how who saw the
performance yesterday yes so a lot of
people saw it some people didn't see it
and it's you reading an essay from
float called
stacks and your collaborator and husband
Robert Curry and an there he is and
another
helper stacking cardboard
boxes on top of each other while you are
reading and and actually
disturbing your
reading we
hope and I've seen this performance many
times and I'm always in the beginning
I'm I'm always I'm almost like annoyed
like why why is all this happening with
the boxes because it's disturbing I want
to hear the
words but then there's something very
moving about it because there's this
tension between attention and
distraction and these are two words that
go through all of your writing can you
talk
about the
distraction well the distraction is
mostly Curry and uh a helper who was Mr
Smith last night Mr Smith and Mr Curry
um have a sort of friendly Warfare with
a bunch of boxes on
stage
and
originally I can't remember remember why
we made this piece but I think we were
invited by somebody to a certain space
where we thought we'd like to use the
whole Space not just do a a normal
reading and um so I wrote a piece about
Stacks the concept of stacking
things um like boxes and then Curry read
it and Curry's function generally in our
collaboration as we like to call it is
to add space to something because I
think of reality as a
sentence uh words on a page and he
thinks of reality as a sculpture a
language as a sculpture and reality as
all kind of things involving space and
people and movement I can't think in
those ways so he puts that stuff into
the words so in this case that stuff
turned out to be um cardboard boxes I
forget why we guess we just had some the
back and um so it becomes a sort of
flurry of activity I don't think of it
as attention and distraction although
originally I I think we started to do
things together he and I because I um
was am uneasy being the center of a
stage wor the spotlight and reading blah
blah blah it always seems to me a little
inadequate as a an evening's
entertainment for you so I thought well
then good idea to move me to the side of
the stage and have something else
happening in the middle and then it
would be interesting for people at least
to watch and so um that's how we began
to uh make things that had these
different parts to them but Lynn thinks
of it as a more maybe conceptually as a
as a tension between a a attention and
distraction which maybe is reasonable
too you you're talking about not wanting
to be in the center of things and that
reminds me of something that M
Cunningham who I know you the the Great
choreographer M Cunningham who lived and
collaborated with uh the composer John
Cage um I know you uh you use a lot of
their work in your work and your encour
work and M Cunningham said something
that
he
understood what it would be to
create a performance um to create a a
new
choreography by going away from the
whole idea of Center Stage M opening up
the stage yeah so it's more it's just as
interesting what happens over there what
happens over there and what happens over
there and it seems to me that that's a
little bit about what you're saying I
think so I think well when we also when
we started to work together Curry and I
he introduced me to John Cage's work and
thinking and um John Cage influenced M
Cunningham in a major way and one of
their Notions was as Lynn says to move
to move the focus of your attention to
the margins of everything happening not
have it just be focused on some person
in the middle so his dancers don't face
always you they face different ways and
they have um almost no expression on
their faces and they don't they don't um
try to focus your your thought on a
point it moves around so I think for a
performance of writing that's um
disturbing as you say but also it breaks
up the event so that you can think into
it at different
places my tendency because I'm a kind of
well I've been a professor all my life
my tendency is to want a lecture and
lecturing is me having a truth and I
insist that you know this truth truth
and you know it in these words I'm going
to give you in no other way and that's
really
tedious and also it isn't really
thinking because it doesn't move you
your mind wants to move and the best
thing a work of art can do is take your
mind with it moving somewhere that you
never expected to
move so I think that's why that's what
we're fond of in M Cunningham
and John Cage are one thing didn't Gert
Stein also say something about moving
things away from the
center yes can we remember that quote
let's
see I can't remember it but something
about moving away
from yeah she says that several
different ways I think it was important
for her too but I mean that's a good
illustration of how hopeless it is to
try to do this because when you think UD
Stein you don't think the margins of
other people around her you think of her
Monumental self in the middle of your
attention so um it's a strange and
hopeless project to lose the self
especially in the middle of making art
works but we keep
trying uh I'd like
to read something that you've written as
the
uh on the back of your a collection of
essays called wrong
Norma wrong Norma is a collection of
writings about different things like
Joseph Conrad Guantanamo flber snow
poverty ret thesaurus my dad Saturday
night the pieces are not linked that's
why I've called them wrong
that doesn't make sense to
you well actually it does but I
I I love your preoccupation with wrong
ah but can you talk about
it well
sure I think be the word wrong a great
word
um came to me uh many years ago somebody
was asking me because I was born in
Canada but I lived I Live Now in in the
United States and Iceland but I I came
to United States to teach there and
people would ask me inevitably at
cocktail parties so what's the
difference between life in Canada and
life in the United States and I never
knew what to say because they don't want
the truth about that so
I took to saying well Canadians are
different than you you rule the world
Canadians are always polite but
wrong and that seemed to me true at the
time still does but anyway I thought
well that's me uh what I'm doing as a as
this Canadian person in America is being
wrong most of the time and it comes out
in in ways
like
this um a collection of pieces of
writing is often thought to be a
coherent whole an experience you know
that works one piece after another to uh
accumulate into a a central idea but
mine don't so there that is I thought
and they always want you to say
something on a book
something embarrassing about how famous
you are so I thought well instead of
that I could just tell people what
they're getting into when they read the
book and that would save a lot of
trouble about things being side by side
or stacked or
wrong not in the center in the
margins you write
um in
the
book about a visit to the lake and
swimming this is uh the essay called one
equals one
yeah and you write about swimming you
you're a swimmer right sometimes yeah
yeah you write a lot about water and
swimming and also here it's beautiful
essay and then you write about the lake
ending to the lake um the swim ending
and then you're right filthy families
and souls in despair pressed flat
against one another in the grip to
survive uncountable arms and legs torn
open eyes locked all night in a train
waiting for Dawn a seen so much the
antithesis of her own
mourning she cannot think it and then
you write this
sentence what sense it makes for these
two mornings to exist side by side in
the world world where we live should
this be framed as a question would not
be answerable by philosophy or poetry or
Finance or the shallows or the deeps of
her own mind she
fears now I would have loved to read
that sentence five more times about the
two mornings existing side by side I
want everyone to go home and read that
essay and read that sentence but can you
talk a little bit about these TR about
the two
mornings the two opposites the Harmony
and the and the and the the terror
existing side by side well the physical
situation out of which that sentence
arises in that story is is that I had a
lovely morning by myself swimming in the
ocean and then went home and read the
newspaper and it was at the time of I
think the ser
Exodus from Syria people were trying to
get out of Syria and go places and there
were stories in in the uh paper about
people trying to go on boats you know
inadequate boats and H uh drowning and
other people in uh very crowded
um uh what do you call them
trains rail by Railway and so it seemed
to me it always seems to me when
contemplating the news as we call it how
you can read a story about tragedy and
Trauma and
um enter into the the Sor of that and
then close the paper and go make toast
you know how do we how do we do that how
do we just let um non-existence be right
side existence and it's okay and I don't
I don't know how we do but we do we have
to it's what we call going on with life
but it always seems to me a problem that
doesn't resolve no matter how you think
into
it has this been yeah go yeah um now I
was thinking
about denz Smith who did an interview
here um a couple days ago he was talking
about this in a more um contemporary way
he was talking about the difficulty of
being him himself he's uh from
Minneapolis he's he's black and an
activist poet um so in his work he
describes things like the death of
people in Minneapolis shot by the police
and he makes a nice poem out of it and
he performs it and people say good poem
and then what does he do with that it's
like we all go home thinking well we
checked that box we dealt with the
police shooting people in Minneapolis
cuz we listen to this poem and it's
that's okay now we go on to the next
problem but you know it isn't okay it's
still just there and that's what poets
like him have to conjure with all the
time time that those two things being
just there and what does he do with that
uh in the presence of you and what does
he do with that after he goes
home is this um
also the
subject or the themes that go through
all you're writing these
things knocking
against each other and not being able to
exist side by side that yeah that it
resistance H yeah it's a kind of
resistance uh reality to the
representations of reality I guess you
would say there's a
collision um which yeah what's the
result of that is that we live in doubt
about whether we can possibly ever be
good people
I was just reading I mean this is really
off the cuff but Lynn elicits that
method of thinking um just thinking
today reading something about day cart
and day cart said this famous sentence
kogito osum I think therefore I am which
everybody knows and learns in school but
if you look at the sentence really it
says dubito Ergo kogito ero suum I doubt
therefore I think therefore I am so that
oh really yes isn't that surprising I
didn't know it either cuz I never looked
it up I had explosions going on in right
I know you see K to air go some on
t-shirts all over the world but dubo has
a bad
press I mean
because thank you thank thank you dck
cart well so that makes me that's very
provocative everything starts in doubt
or it also could mean hesitation but
same idea on hesitation you have written
a whole essay called on hesitation I did
write an essay on hesitation what is it
the word what is it with doubt
hesitation
that that you grapple with uh that's a
good question I think I wrote the
lecture um in order to investigate that
question and it really got nowhere but
the interesting thing about that lecture
was I did it to because I got invited to
do a lecture at the prao Museum in
Madrid and I thought wow that's cool I'm
really a cool person now and then I
wrote this lecture and you know lectures
they start somewhere with a question
then they go God knows where because
thought you know has its own paths end
up being a lecture about Chipmunks
which they don't have in Spain so the
whole underpinning of the thought was
just uh pretty remote for them but
anyway but also by goya's dog I seem to
remember yeah Goya enters into I tried
to put in Spanish stuff you know after I
realized it was all about Chipmunks so
fortunately Goya has a
painting you've probably seen this
painting when you look at it you think
it's a detail of a painting because it's
a huge uh sort of gold colored canvas
with down in this corner a little dog's
head just the head of a dog looking um
with some expression that people all see
differently looking up at the at the
hole above the space above and is
fascinating
painting but we
digress well that's what we're supposed
to do so good I want to go back a little
bit to
float
that's it has stuff on it I'm
sorry um peanut butter well something
um it's in little
pamphlets there's something about and I
want to come back to that some several
of your books are I mean they're
physical objects they're physical
objects art objects or objects I
remember first time I was um you and
Curry introduced me to float I think
Curry sort of did a a kind of very
dramatic gesture where he sort of threw
all the
pamphlets over the audience um because
you can do that too you can read it and
you can throw
it
[Music]
um there is a an
essay
inflat called Uncle falling
it's one of my one of my many favorite
essays and that has a an
autobiographical um scene to
it and I was wondering if you could read
a little bit from Uncle falling it's
about your Uncle Harry yeah great uncle
my dad's Uncle yeah great uncle and what
was it about Uncle Harry Uncle Harry was
was a
Hermit he lived um in the Northern woods
of Canada by himself with a dog and two
horses and um he was I don't know was he
crazy he was very inward person very uh
had his own view of reality and he just
didn't want to live with other people so
he withdrew to the a farm uh and um died
there but he got you know dementia at
the end of his life and that was sad but
until that time he was a really
admirable person and he was a figure in
my childhood because he was always there
on the farm when we went for summer
vacations as we did he didn't speak much
he was deaf and he got deaf by jumping
into the lake uh when he was a kid and
burst his
eardrum um and because he was deaf I
guess he didn't find it pleasurable to
mix with other people so um but I think
he wouldn't have wanted to live with
other people anyway however yeah he was
deaf and kind of sad but always
helpful
so you want to stand when oh I don't no
I don't want to stand in space like no
all by
myself oh just sit l
the loneliness yeah um this is about him
about Uncle Harry it's called the
loneliness was he
lonely I don't know 9 months of the year
he lived alone on a farm in the north of
Ontario a near town was 5 miles away a
near neighbor
uncertain most land around the lake had
been parceled out in cottage Lots years
ago
cottagers are seasonal some come for
Christmas or a weekend in Winter most
board up their cottages on the last day
of August and reappear in June it was a
long deep winter Harry had by himself
with his dog and his two horses and his
subscription to the National Geographic
Society
magazine snow drifted up to the eaves
his Hay Wagon got him to town every two
weeks for supplies he ate tins of corn
beef hash and green peas and coffee he
liked now and then an oh Henry chocolate
bar until probably the middle of may he
lived in two rooms of The Farmhouse
namely the kitchen which had the stove
and the bedroom directly above which had
the stove
pipe other rooms whispered with
ice and then 3 months in summer Harry's
world chilled suddenly up the Cottages
came back and so did we who's we Harry
was the brother of my father's mother
Ethel Ethel had four children including
my father and they all had children and
the children all had friends week after
week in summer these people arrived in
groups of 3 to 10 the idea was to help
Harry bring in the hay this was the
phrase they used and to enjoy enjoy a
vacation at the lake this idea was not
Harry's I never heard him comment on it
he did comment on the inability of my
father and my uncles to master cing
technique Harry could scye 100 square
meters of hay in 3 and 1 half minutes
leaving a patch as level as his mustache
with Fallen stocks un bruised there was
frustration and a red-faced man in the
Hayfield many an
afternoon Harry remained unfailingly
polite to everyone so did the dog whose
name was Shep although it was a
succession of dogs and so did the horses
Prince and Florence who were Immortal at
that
time thank you
[Music]
you know reading through your work again
we reading this
summer it strikes
me
um how much of your writing is
seemingly
autobiographical
um it's not the first thing that even I
have thought about with you that you
know there's snitches here and there but
this time reading I you know there's
there's the mother and daughter in glass
essay uh the mother appears again
although that's maybe not
autobiographical I don't know in in red
the autobiograph autobiography of red
and red dock there's the mother and of
course here's the great uncle your dad
appears from time to time husbands the
beautiful husband um
you know there's debates from time and
time again about autobiography and
writing and what what is your
relationship to writing
autobiographically and is I'm appalled
by
[Laughter]
it and every time I sit down to write
anything I'm determined not to do that
but really you have no other story to
tell you know or no other understanding
of reality that except the one you've
lived so it keeps coming
up but um yeah I don't like it I don't
know what to do about
that I guess now we have autofiction
which is supposed to be somehow free of
this question but I don't understand
why do
you I I think I read somewhere that you
well I read two quotes two different
interviews one where you were asked this
question and you said well I'm not canow
scored which I agree and then in another
essay or another um interview you said
well I have no
imagination that's also I don't like to
make up things is that true
yeah basically that's
true I can't make up
stories I have friends who were
novelists and they just wake up every
day with a story in their mind of what
they could make a novel out of I've
never never had that but if I stub my
toe on the way to the bathroom then I
can write about that because it just
happened it's
real just two kinds of people you
know it's lovely in um glass essay she's
out in Danish now recently in a new
edition um glass ironing God I mean the
description of the mother and the
grown-up daughter is just so beautiful
with the mother and it's small things
you know how the mother sits at the
breakfast table and things she does
making breakfast so it's these little
things that are
poignant I guess that's true I guess I
think that's
what uh the task of a writer is to just
notice small Small
Things
cuz noticing large things is for people
like
dayart
basically uh I and I can't do that but
noticing small things makes a
difference
why um
because mostly what we do
especially in relation to other people
and even more especially in relation to
the other people in our family is to
assume that we know them and sort of
smear across them in daily life mother's
always in the other room complaining
about something um
and I've learned I mean it's only taken
74 years I've learned to pay attention
to things people do anyway things people
do or how they do things outside of The
Stereotype I already have of of them and
then it's always
surprising it's always
surprising I find this is true not just
with the family but with I've been doing
um Lynn wants to talk about this later
I've been going to Boxing class
lately and a boxing class is a kind of
constant core of people who go all the
time and we sort of have come to know
each other
other and um they're very different
people than me cuz I'm I've always been
a academic so I'm basically uh an
arrogant intellectual thinking I'm a
little better than everybody else
because I read all these books um and
these people in the boxing class are not
mostly uh academics or intellectuals in
fact they don't read at all as far as I
can see they watch TV and they come to
Boxing class and I I could dismiss them
therefore because they're not like me
and I gradually learned not to do that
and when you don't do that then you
begin to see that they're each
actually pretty unique probably crazy
and willing to be nice to you so I just
you know that kind of attention to
details leads you somewhere truer than
generalizing I would
say since you now mentioned boxing you
suggested actually backstage that if we
run out of things to say we could always
box but
Curry um you have written about boxing
also um I have and I I want you to read
from that essay in London Review of
Books it's it's one of your latest
essays and it's it's a remarkable essay
also about attention and about boxing
and handwriting but your collaborator
and Curry gave sent me a
[Laughter]
picture we have two of them
[Music]
[Applause]
I should emphasize this was not my
idea I think we should raffle these off
at the end yeah give the money to the
Louisiana Museum
yes so Curry is showing everyone and
here's another one and I'm going to put
it here anyway yeah I
started I started to do boxing class
because uh as I don't know maybe you
know this I have this disease called
Parkinson's which is a
neurological disorder and um it
interferes with attention as well as
with physical movement and one of the
recommended therapies for this this uh
disease is boxing because it teaches you
to pay attention to hand eye
coordination of movement and um also to
uh sequences of actions because boxing
workouts are a sequence of different
kinds of punches um which are uh
dictated by the the teacher they call
out numbers and you have to do the
motion that corresponds to that number
so you have to pay attention in a
particular way that if you have
Parkinson your brain doesn't want to do
so you have to keep um stimulating your
brain to do that thing so boxing
therefore is why I mean that's why I
began the boxing and I really like it
how long have you been boxing no oh how
long two or three months maybe I just
yeah I just joined it
recently I asked you I I made a print of
the essay in the London review books and
everybody has to go and read this whole
essay but I um and it was printed in
August and I'm wondering if you would
read the beginning of that essay um okay
thank you speaking of not wanting to be
autobiographical oh
well this uh essay was called gloves on
because that's
a phrase that is used it's um explained
here so your life there it is before you
possibly a road a ribbon a dotted line a
map let's say you're 25 then you make
some decisions do things have setbacks
have triumphs become someone a bus
driver a professor a pirate a
cosmetologist years past maybe in a
family Maybe not maybe happy maybe not
then one day you wake up and you're a 70
looking ahead you see a black doorway
you begin to notice the black doorway is
always there at the edge whether you
look at it or not most moments contain
it most moments have a sort of sediment
of black doorway at the bottom of the
glass you wonder if other people are
seeing it too you ask them they say no
you ask why no one can tell
you a minute ago you were 25 then you
went ahead getting the life you want one
day you looked back from 25 to now and
there it is the doorway black
waiting when I was diagnosed with
Parkinson's disease a symptom
particularly mortifying to me was that
my handwriting disintegrated
Parkinson's as you know maybe is a
shaking disease so most people who get
it have a trimmer like your hand does
this and it makes handwriting obviously
difficult um I used to take pleasure in
writing in notebooks shelves of them day
after day year after
year now the upright Strokes Bend or
break or go in all directions vowels
shrink to blobs slant loses its smooth
smart angle it all looks embarrassing I
scrub out whole paragraphs in
shame hard to describe or explain the
shame of bad
handwriting the shame of bad handwriting
[Music]
[Applause]
so handwriting I don't know should we
talk about handwriting yeah let's talk
about handwriting how many people
learned to write cursive in
school you all did wow well the
Europeans did you did
too I think nowadays it's not so much
cared about because people even in
elementary school they're reading on the
screen a lot anyway I I did too learn to
write cursive in elementary school and I
just LED doing it I remember especially
the joy of getting to the letter s all
those curves you know it's really just
extraordinary fun anyway over the years
I've written in notebooks with you know
a pen uh day after day and I enjoyed
just the the movement of the thing line
after line no matter what it said it's a
different category of pleasure from the
thinking of what to write and um and
when your handwriting becomes
uncontrollable that's that pleasure is
lost um most people who have Parkinson
start to print instead of writing but
printing isn't much
fun so um yeah that was the pro
provocation for this essay was how
frustrated I was by not being able to
write by hand and it is interesting I
don't understand this exactly
how that situation inhibits the thinking
of what to write I guess the pleasures
were so inter interl that now when I
think to sit down write something I stop
because it would be horrible trying to
make the the marks work and I can't seem
to type
thoughts it's
different have you always written by
hand
yeah but you say in this essay this
remarkable essay because you have
written it by hand mhm
um it's like it's two forces in that
essay there's
this this incredible energy I
mean you know gloves
on mhm and then at one point you say or
you write life is no longer
fair and you
say and I think it's like your whole
work your whole body of work is embodied
this one sentence which is the struggle
you're speaking of now I strive I do not
win it's Becket you know it's it's yeah
I strive I do not win which I think is
you know
so yeah so in this essay I mean it's
it's a
masterpiece because again it's these
two things side by side you mhm you
you're ashamed of your handwriting
you're right it's shameful because yeah
and then at the same time it's gloves on
yeah yeah well aren't we all we're all
kind of in that boat all the time that
sort of
struggle I mean what what else would you
do but also I'll put in here a
parenthesis that sentence life is not
fair is a pun
there because it follows right after
saying I
envy Keats cuz if you've ever looked at
Kat's um letters and Diaries they're
written by hand in this beautiful um
form formal kind of uh cursive and
they're some of the most uh lovely
surfaces I've ever seen and he called
those his fair copies and I writing fair
I remember writing fair with great
difficulty and thinking fair that has a
lot of other meanings besides nice
looking yes because in English tell me
about the different meanings of fair
well fair in English means pretty
basically nice comly pleasant to look at
but it also means
just um equal equ equal distributed
among the
players so that's quite a different
thing but I lost
both you have been a translator your
whole
life
um and in float there is a um essay that
I love called very s um the right to
remain
silent and in it well you there's so
much in that essay but in it you speak
of the silences in
Translation there's a lot of Silence in
your
translations um obviously in in your
translations of of
sapo because things have literally I
mean you don't have the whole poem there
are brackets and you you make the
brackets as important as the words so
the silence is what's disappeared what's
no longer there what we don't know the
black spaces are as important as the
words can you talk about the meaning
of working with disappeared things or
silent things blank spaces in writing
and
translation I think I think um as far as
safo
goes um I put blank spaces in um to
represent the history of the text
because most of her work is has been
lost to us so that it seems um simply
unrealistic to read uh translations that
fill out her lines and make a complete
story out of something of which we only
really know 11 words so I put the spaces
in for that reason and then I put
brackets to indicate where the spaces
start and stop mostly I did that because
it looked nice to be honest but it is
something that classical Scholars do
with with textual criticism they use
different kinds of
brackets um but I suppose it relates to
the cognitive procedure of translation
where you're always coming upon words
that can't be uh imitated in the other
language let alone
replicated and so that uh those holes in
the meaning are always there for the
mind of the translator and usually
you're meant to
U uh relieve the reader of the problem
of having that so you fill them in or
cover them up but um I didn't do that
another
wrongness you do the opposite you draw
attention draw attention to the
blankness to the things that don't yeah
and I suppose
um I suppose it gives also a space for
thinking as I was saying before
for part of a project of of writing or
making artworks is to give other people
a thinking that they haven't had before
and having language with space in it is
a a place to go and
think and well I actually it's
interesting how since I published that
book I can't tell you how often I've
received in the mail manuscripts by
people who have helpfully filled in all
the spaces
because I get they read it and they
think they know what she said so or
should have
said but that's a a reparative Instinct
maybe trying to make good the holes I
don't
know don't know what to say about it
either to
them I usually send them back saying
thank you very much
um uh in an interview you did on the in
in the podcast at the radio program to
Elanor Vel who is here in at Louisiana
the writers and Company great fantastic
book
podcast you tell her that you love being
in the
translation did I wow
yeah and she asks you why and you say
because you can Glimpse down the
cracks at the that other thing ah at
that other thing what's
that the Glimpse I mean I guess it's
what you've already been saying that you
know it's the cracks yeah looking down
at something that's cracked and not
whole yeah maybe so and and otherness in
it I think yeah maybe so maybe so it's
translation is a a weird process you
have the original and your version and
then you have in between them glimpsed
maybe that crack in the book in between
the two parts you have what it should
say the language in between those two
things but it doesn't you can't get to
that from either side they said what
they said and you say some imitation of
it but there could be a word a set of
words that does both at
once except we don't live in that time
zone what do you mean we don't live in
that time zone well we don't I mean
that's sort of like string theory there
could be all these different realities
and we're just happen to be living in
this one but we could be living in that
one or we could be living in the crack
because it's there somewhere but we
haven't learned how to perceive it or
it's like Walter Benjamin has this
famous essay about the task of the
translator where he calls that the
sacred conversation that one down
underneath the
two so I don't know about sacred I'm not
that uh sure about sacred anything but
that's a a way to describe that you do
say in from variations on the right to
remains silent you say there is
something maddeningly attractive about
the
untranslatable about a word that goes
silent in
transit that's well put isn't
it I think
[Applause]
so
um also in that essay about translation
and one of the reasons I and many
reasons I love it you talk about hin or
you write about hin who actually went
mad translating himself yeah yeah well
he started translating
Sophocles you've also translated
Sophocles and he just never felt that he
got it right and then he started sort of
R translating himself yeah and then he
went mad yeah perhaps some of you who
are writers have done that I mean you
look at your old books as written by
somebody else and then you think I could
do that better nowadays and if you start
trying it's a black
hole that goes you really are a
different
person but um yeah where did you start
that I
forget Walter Benjamin no Walter
Benjamin yeah about um Madness and
holderlin oh holdin yeah holderlin went
mad
and he
yeah go on he just I think uh the
process was he was alone he lived alone
in a tower he was certified insane lived
alone in a
tower by a river and he began
to reread his own work and break it down
into different ways of saying the same
thing I guess and then started to
translate it himself into
himself quite yeah bizarre have you
attempted something like that ever no I
just don't read the old stuff Sol the
problem but you do say or write some
other place that Madness lives right
next to
poetry me say that yeah you said that
dang
imagine what I meant by
that in connection to holderlin or to no
me he said
it I I try to make order with my notes
so I have this whole page called
translation and Madness and it just says
quote no you said it to me an Carson
said to
me poetry is right next to Madness in
the mind so you're you know just a step
away so okay it's in an earlier
conversation you've said this to me must
have been something you said the
provoker I can't
remember well it's a platonic idea that
Madness and poetry and the lover and the
poet and the madman are side by side
psychologically in some kind of uh set
of assumptions about how they should
live probably I was quoting Plato
you know before we end I I want to go
back
to to the mother figure that appears
from time to time in the glass essay in
autobiography of red in red
dock that's on top of my mind I remember
and just
this beautiful
mother
character and
in red
dock
um this we meet uh the the red monster
gion again uh we meet him also in
autobiography of red and he's he's sort
of on a road trip and then he ends up
with
his dying mother
mhm and uh
it's it's very poignant and I just
reread it you know and everybody who's
had mothers or who are mothers or
remembers mothers it's
um it's very beautiful I even thought
about but that's probably me taking it
too far because this Gary and coming to
his mother's bedside it reminded me a
little bit of per gint Ipson perint this
is me being Norwegian sitting by his
mother mother's bedside and tell D the
dying mother and telling you know
everything they're going to do together
but uhhuh is do you have I mean there's
so many playwrights that play play a
role in your life is isson I never not
so far nope no not so far so that perant
essay was probably just me but the
mother you know she's there in the glass
essay which is one of your earlier Works
she's there in your later
works can you say something not the same
mother I don't think is it not the same
mother is that was just me then the one
in autobiography of red um well I guess
maybe she's always smoking for one thing
my mother did smoke um pretty much all
the time but the rest of the personality
is not the same no but the one in the
mother in other parts that you mentioned
red dock I think is more like uh what
really happened
yeah yeah because I think you did say in
an interview that writing this the the
death scene or sitting by the mother's
deathbed was was was
um was
hard yeah it was hard she was uh not
happy but what she was worried about
mostly and this was is
saddening uh was her
eyebrows she used to pluck her eyebrows
every day she had really bushy eyebrows
and in the cosmetology of that time it
was a few years ago um bushy eyebrows
were not in fashion they are now
actually so different world she had a
lot of worry about being in a hospital
where she couldn't do her eyebrows every
day and just looking terrible so when I
went to visit her in the hospital what
we tried to do together was have me
pluck her eyebrows which if you've ever
tried to do that is just
impossible and anyway as I kept telling
her her eyebrows were transparent I mean
she was totally white haired and your
eyebrows when you they get white they
just disappear into your skin it didn't
matter whether she plucked her eyebrows
or not and I kept making this point and
she just ignored me which was typical of
our experience together to that time but
it was also kind of sad that she was
still you know worried about this as it
seemed to me an essential thing but
that's who we
are I want
[Music]
to end this talk actually by you reading
from Red dock
um I have it I had had it from Kindle so
I we wrote it on a page but this is
thank you about mother in red Doc and I
was wondering if you
could yeah I should explain uh the
formal
structure uh red dock is a novel sort of
inverse but it has
um a Greek chorus or a chorus that
recurs in the same voice and the chorus
is called wife of brain so it's a a sort
of indeterminate voice that oversees the
action and the thoughts of the
characters so this is wife of
brain mothers in summer mothers in
Winter mothers in Autumn mothers in
Spring mothers at altitude mothers in
solitude mothers as platitude mothers in
Spring
mothers banking their shots mothers
crackling their throats mothers dumped
from their boats in Spring mothers as
ice or when they are nice no one more
nice in
Spring mothers ashamed and Ablaze and
clear at the end as they are as they
almost all are and then mothers Don't
Come Around again in
Spring and Carson
[Applause]
than